ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิง
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
นักเรียนทุกคนเป็นยังไงบ้างสบายดีค่ะอะ
สบายดีแข็งแรงครูฟ้าล่ะคะเป็นยังไงคะสบาย
ดีค่ะสบายดีมากดีค่ะครูฟ้าคะวันนี้วัน
อะไร
วันนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 6 เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตอะไรคะปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะอ่ะและเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
ตาลเมื่อวานนี้วันอังคารค่ะ
คุณที่เท่าไหร่หรือคะวันที่ 5
ดีเดือน
เมษายน
ปีพตตปีพต 2  5  6 ห้าปีคศ
ปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันพฤหัสบดีค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 7 เดือนเมษายน
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 มีของค่ะค่ะแล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมง
คะครูฟ้าตอนนี้เวลา 5 โมง
5 โมงกี่นาทีคะ
48 นาทีค่ะ
48 นาทีก็เป็นตอนเย็นหรอ 17:00 น 17:00
นแล้ววันนี้นะคะครูหญิงมีคำถาม
วันนี้เนี่ยวันนี้ว่าอะไรนะคะวันพุธเนาะ
มันพุธที่ 6 นะคะวันพุธที่ 6 ปีมีคำถาม
และถามครูฟ้านะคะถามครูฟ้าวันนี้วันพุธ
ที่ 6 ครูหญิงเนี่ยใส่เสื้อเสื้อสีอะไร
สีฟ้าผู้หญิงสีฟ้าแล้วเมื่อวานนี้เมื่อ
แต่เมื่อวานนี้วันอังคาร
วันที่ 5 ครูฟ้าเนี่ยจำได้ไหมครูหญิงใส่
เสื้อสีอะไร
เมื่อวานนี้สีขาวผู้ฟ้าบอกว่าสีขาวสีขาว
ผิดค่ะ
สีดำสีดำสีดำผิดค่าสีน้ำตาล
สีน้ำตาลเหมือนกาแฟเนี่ยเหรอสีน้ำตาลตาล
ผิดค่าสีเขียว
สีเขียว
เนี่ยเนาะสีเขียว
ผิดค่า
สีเหลือง
สีเหลืองอุ้ยหมีป่าสิ่งนะสีเหลืองเนี่ยสี
เหลืองน้ำสีเหลืองผิด
แต่ถ้าสีอะไรมาคุยหญิงเลือกไหม
สีชมพู
สีชมพูสีชมพูสีชมพู
โอคาร่า
สีชมพู
เอาแต่คุณฟ้าอาจจะเห็นครูฟ้าทำไม่ได้อ้ะ
เค้าไม่มีเยอะกูหญิงใส่เสื้อสีชมพูอยู่
ที่นี่เลยไม่มีแล้ววันนี้ครูฟ้าจะโอเคไหม
เพราะว่าครูหญิงเนี่ยจะมีเกมเกี่ยวกับ
ความจำวิตามิรูปให้ครูฟ้าดูนะฮะแล้วก็มี
เวลาสมัย 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10
10 วินาที
เวลา 10 วินาทีครูฟ้าต้องดูแล้วก็จะจำจำ
และผู้หญิงก็จะปิด
แล้วก็จะมีคำถาม
ถามครูฟ้าว่าครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมเช็คนะคะ
น่าจะจำได้น่าจะทำใดโอเคค่ะเพราะไม่ครู
ฟ้า
พร้อมค่ะได้ค่ะเดี๋ยวครูหญิง Share
screen ก่อนนะคะ
เห็นเนาะเห็นกูฟ้าเห็นแล้วอ่ะ
แฮปปี้ไปก่อนนะอ้าว
นี่ไงจะมีรูปทั้งหมดนะคะ 1  2  3  4  5  6
6 รูปให้ครูฟ้าดูแต๋วครูฟ้าต้องจำนะคะ
รูปภาพพร้อมมั้ย
พร้อมกับผู้หญิงโอเคนะคะ 1
1  2  3 เริ่มค่ะ
3  4  4  5  5  6  6  7  8  9  10 หมด
เวลาหมดเวลาอ่ะครูฟ้า
คุยจะมีคำถามก่อนนะคุยกับถาม 2 ข้อค่ะว่า
อะไร 1 และข้อที่สองนะคะอะข้อที่ 1 นะคะ
ครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมว่ารูปนี้นะคะนาฬิกาปลุก
นาฬิกาปลุกครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมว่านาฬิกาปลุก
อยู่ที่หมายเลขอะไร
หมายเลข
1 ค่ะฟ้าบอกข้อ 1 นะนาฬิกาปลุกอยู่ที่มี
ผู้หมายเลข 1
ไม่รู้ค่ะอ่ะข้อที่สองนะคะโรงเรียนอันนี้
คือโรงเรียนครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมว่าโรงเรียน
อยู่หมายเลขอะไร
หมายเลข 5 ค่ะ
บอกหมายเลข 5
ไปดูเฉลยค่ะว่านาฬิกาปลุกกับโรงเรียน
เนี่ยนะคะจะอยู่หมายเลข 1 กับหมายเลข 5
เหมือนที่ครูฟ้าจำได้หรือเปล่าได้เลยโอเค
1  2
3  4  5 อัมพรแล้วไม่ค่อยสอง 2 ผู้หญิง
ก็รับอะไรคะ
ดูค่ะ
ลูกค้าบอกว่านาฬิกาปลุกอยู่หมายเลข 1
สมัยถ้าอุ้ยดีใส่แล้วหรอคะที่ยังไม่ได้
เฉลยเลยเอา
หมายเลข 1 อันนี้หมายเลขเลย
5  6
พ่อหมายเลข 1 นะคะก็เป็นนาฬิกาปลุกคู่ฟ้า
ถูกค่ะ
เลข 5 เป็นโรงเรียนครูพระถูกค่ะเย้
ตำได้นะฟ้าจำได้นะคะ
ต่อไปค่ะ
ได้ค่ะรับตาก่อนหลับตาไม่ให้ครูฟ้าเห็น
ฟ้าหลับตา
ครูฟ้าลืมตาได้ค่ะเปิดหน้าลืมตาได้โอเค
แล้วก็จะมีรูปให้ครูฟ้าดู
6 รูปเหมือนเดิมนะคะมีเวลา 10 วินาที
ได้ค่ะพร้อมไหมคะพร้อมค่ะโอเค 1  2
3  1  2  3  4  4  5  5  6  7  8  9  10
หมดเวลาค่ะ
โอเคครูหญิงก็จะมีคำถาม
ข้อที่ 1 และก็ข้อที่สองนะคะเหมือนเดิมนะ
คะ
ข้อที่ 1 ถามว่าอะไรคะรูปอะไรคะครูฟ้า
ดาวน์ค่ะดาวน์ครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมดาวอยู่หมาย
เลขอะไร
ดาวหนะ
ผมจำได้ไหม
ดาวอยู่หมายเลข 3 ค่ะบอกดาวอยู่หมายเลข 3
นะคะอะรูปต่อไปรูปอะไรคะลา
ครูฟ้า
ครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมปลาอยู่หมายเลขอะไร
ปลาอยู่หมายเลข 1 ไฟฟ้าบอกหนึ่งนะคะไม่
รู้ครูหญิงจำไม่ได้นะคะจริง
อ่ะเรามาดูเฉลยค่ะ
แฟน
เย้ๆๆ
J ใช่ไหมคะอันนี้หมายเลข 1 หมายเลข 1
หมายเลข 1
อ้าาครูฟ้าแต่ว่าดาวอยู่หมายเลข 3
หารชา
อยู่หมายเลขหนึ่งถูกต้องค่ะครูฟ้าจำได้นะ
จำได้
เพลงมากไฟฟ้าหลับตาล้วนปิดตาค่ะ
ถ้าเปิดได้ค่ะ
อ้าว
เหมือนเดิมนี่ไม่เหมือนผู้หญิงกูฟ้าเห็น
เป็นปลาดาวกดผิดค่ะเอาใหม่ๆๆโอเคกี้ตานะ
นักเรียน
ฟ้าไม่ต้องปิดตาก็ได้ค่ะอ้าว
โอเคโอเคอ่าเดี๋ยวผู้หญิงแชร์ใหม่นะคะ
เมื่อกี้นี้กดผิดนะคะไป Stop แชร์
โอเคมาแล้วก็เห็นไหมคะอ่ะก็เห็ดนี่นาแล้ว
ไม่ใช่ 6 รูปนะคะมีทั้งหมดกี่รูปครูฟ้ามี
ทั้งหมด 10 รูป
10 รูปนะมีเวลา
10 วินาทีโอเคไหมโง่โอเคก็ได้โอเคนะครู
ฟ้าเค้าจำเก่งนะ 10 วินาทีพอแล้วนะคะอ่ะ
ครูฟ้าพร้อมนะคะน้อมค่ะ
1  2  3 เริ่มค่ะหนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้าหก
เจ็ดแปดเก้าสิบห้าครบแล้ว
สิบนะคะเดี๋ยวกูหญิงดูก่อนว่าผู้หญิง
เนี่ยมีคำถามนะคะถามครูฟ้า
เอาอ่ะโอ๊ยโอ๊ย
มีคำถามถามครูฟ้าอะข้อที่ 1 อะไรคะครูฟ้า
ถ้ากุ้งนะคะกุ้งก้า
ครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมกุ้งอยู่หมายเลขอะไร
กุ้งอยู่หมายเลข
77 หน้าครูฟ้าบอกว่าปุ้งอยู่หมายเลข 7
ไม่รู้
7 อะไรครับรูฟ้ามีร้ายค่ะ
ยีราฟนะคะครูฟ้าจำได้ไหม
ยีราฟนะยีราฟหน่อยนะคะ
ยีราฟอยู่หมายเลขอะไร
ยีราฟอยู่หมายเลข 3 ครูสาวบอกอยู่หมายเลข
คำถาม
ยังไม่หมด
ข้อที่ 3 สิงโต
งานสิงโตครูฟ้าจำได้ไหมสิงโตอยู่หมายเลข
อะไร
สิงโตอยู่หมายเลข 10
10 นะอะครูฟ้าบอกกุ้งอยู่ไหนได้ 7 เยอะ
ร้ายอยู่หมายเลข 3 สิงโตอยู่หมายเลข 10
นะคะมาดูว่าครูฟ้ามาแล้วไม่รู้ครูฟ้าจัด
จำได้ไหม
โอเคนะคะ
เดี๋ยวคุณตอบถูกหรอ
6  1
2  3  4  5
ม 6
ที่ 7
10 กะครูฟ้าบอกว่ากุ้งอยู่หมายเลข 7 ใช่
ไหมคะไม่ใช่
ไม่ใช่กุ้งอยู่หมายเลขอะไร
หมายเลข 6 ค่ะครูฝาจำไม่ได้นะจำไม่ได้นะ
คะแล้วยีราฟอยู่หมายเลข 3 ใช่ไหมคะให้หา
ยีราฟอยู่หมายเลข 3 อันนี้ครูฟ้าจำได้นะ
คะแล้วก็สุดท้าย
สิงโตอยู่หมายเลข 10 ใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะสิงโต
อยู่หมายเลข 10 นี่ก็ครูฟ้าจำได้สมัยครู
ฟ้าจำได้ว่าสิงโต
ยีราฟชชอยู่หมายเลขอะไรแต่ครูฟ้าจำไม่ได้
ขอให้นะคะว่ากุ้งอยู่หมายเลขอะไร
คุยชนะบ้าง
ต่อไปค่ะครูบางสำหรับตาข่ายหรือว่าปิดตา
โอเค
อ่ะกูฟ้าเปิดได้ค่ะ
เย้
ลูกค้าพร้อมไหมคะพร้อมค่ะหนึ่งสองสาม
หนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้าหกเจ็ดแปดเก้าสิบ
โอเคอ่ะครูฟ้าอะไรคะถังขยะค่ะครูฟ้าจำได้
ไหมว่าถังขยะ
อยู่หมายเลขอะไร
ถังขยะอยู่หมายเลขมาดูหนัง 5 ฟ้าบอกอยู่
หมายเลข 5 นะคะ
ไม่รู้หมายเลข 7 หมายเลข 7 เปลี่ยนใจ
เปลี่ยนใจบอกผ่านไม่ขยะอยู่หมายเลข 7
แล้วเก้นได้ค่ะจริงจำไม่ได้ไม่เป็นไรค่ะ
ค่ะต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้าคะอันนี้อะไรคะตำรวจค่ะ
ฟ้าจำได้ไหมว่าจรวดอยู่หมายเลขอะไร
4  4
นะคะ 4
ไม่รู้นะ
อันนี้อะไรคะฟ้าโทรศัพท์ค่ะโทรศัพท์ครู
ฟ้าจำได้ไหมว่าโทรศัพท์
อยู่หมายเลขอะไร
หมายเลข 6 รูฟ้าบอกว่าหมายเลข 6 น่ะอ้ะ
ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเขาจำว่าถังขยะอยู่หมายเลข 7
หัว
จรวดอยู่หมายเลข 4
โทรศัพท์โทษโทรศัพท์อยู่หมายเลข 6
มาดูกันค่ะว่าครูฟ้าเขาจะจำได้ทั้งหมดไหม
เออๆ
เขาจะรู้แล้วนะคะหมายเลขอะไรคะคือฟ้าแม่
มึงค่ะ
2  3  3  4  4  5  5  6  6  7  8  9  10
15 ค่ะๆครูฟ้าบอกว่าถังขยะอยู่หมายเลข 7
เสร็จฮ่าๆๆ
ถูกค่ะค่ะครูฟ้าจำได้ตอนแรกเค้าบอกหมาย
เลข 5 ใช่ไหมแล้วก็ไปอย่าง
ข้อที่สองนะคะจรวดสีฟ้าบอกว่าอยู่หมายเลข
4 ใช่ไหมคะ
มีใคร
วงศาก็จำได้นะฮะแล้วก็สุดท้ายค่ะโทร
โทรศัพท์นะนุ่นสับอยู่หมายเลข 6 ใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ขาย
ป่าก่อนจำได้สมัยไฟฟ้าจำได้ว่าจรวด
โทรศัพท์ถังขยะอยู่หมายเลขอะไรนะคะในรูป
มาจำไม่ได้อย่างเดียวก็คือกุ้ง
ครูฟ้าจำไว้ว่ากุ้งอยู่หมายเลขอะไรกูว่า
คุณชอบกุ้งไม่ใช่เหรอคะ
ใกล้กันเนี่ย 6 เน็ต
เหงาวันนี้ก็จริงๆเก่งมากนะคะ
ถ้าเก้าเปอร์เซ็นต์เหมือนคู่ฟ้าแหละ
99 เปอร์เซ็นต์
ป๊าจำได้แต่ไม่อาจจะแค่ 1% จำไม่ได้นะคะ
แล้วก็จำไม่ได้ว่าครูหญิงใส่เสื้อสีอะไร
แต่ครูหญิงก็จำไม่ได้นะคะเมื่อวานครูฟ้า
ใส่เสื้อสีอะไรปลาก็จำไม่ได้เขาว่ากูใส่
เสื้อสีอะไร
อ่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้หมดเวลาแล้วไหมคะเหมือน
เวลาแล้วค่ะเราจะต้องแล้วเจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนไปแล้วค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ